aquí tenemos un diagrama simplificado de
la electrólisis del cloruro de sodio
fundido verdad y si fundimos cloruro de
sodio sólido por supuesto
entonces obtenemos iones de sodio
líquido también obtenemos uniones de
cloro líquido y eso es justamente lo que
tenemos en este dibujo verdad tenemos
iones de sodio y uniones de cloro y
recordemos que en una celda
electrolítica la terminal negativa de la
batería libera electrones cierto libera
electrones en esta dirección ahora en
este caso libera los electrones hacia el
electrodo que tenemos del lado derecho y
cuando estos iones de sodio entran en
contacto con estos electrones obtenemos
una una semi reacción de reducción así
que déjenme escribir esto vamos a tener
una semi reacción de reducción verdad y
es la que tenemos justamente por acá
tenemos que los iones de sodio verdad
van a ganar electrones y se van a
reducir en una
forma líquida de sodio metálico así que
en esencia el sodio metálico es uno de
nuestros productos para esta reacción
que tenemos aquí abajo verdad y esto
formaría es esto se formaría justamente
en el cátodo déjenme ponerlo aquí aquí
tenemos el cátodo y podemos dibujar un
poco de metal de sodio líquido verdad
quizás debería ponerlo algo más clarito
digamos así verdad aquí se forman en el
cátodo la otra semi reacción verdad que
tenemos en el otro electrodo sabemos que
en este caso nuestra batería va a jalar
electrones de desde este electrodo
verdad va a jalar los desde acá así que
aquí tenemos un fenómeno de oxidación
verdad la oxidación está ocurriendo en
este electrodo y por lo tanto esto sería
el ánodo verdad así que tenemos uniones
líquidos de cloro verdad que están
siendo oxidados verdad se están oxidando
en gas de cloro así que estamos
perdiendo esencialmente dos electrones
nuestros uniones se convierten en cloro
gaseoso y obtenemos dos electrones y eso
es lo que ocurre en este electrodo
verdad entonces por supuesto aquí se
estarían formando nuestras burbujas de
nuestro cloro gaseoso muy bien y esta
reacción es sumamente importante en la
industria verdad por ejemplo si
quisiéramos formar sodio metálico este
es una muy buena forma de hacerlo así
que la prueba
es cuánto tiempo lleva a producir 1.00
por 10 a la 3 kilogramos de sodio con
una corriente constante de 3.00 por 10 a
la 4 enteres así que tenemos otro
problema de electrólisis cuantitativa
verdad así que este va a ser por
supuesto un poquito más difícil que el
que vimos anteriormente pero vamos a
tratar de empezar de la misma forma así
que vamos a hacernos un poco de espacio
primero vamos a empezar con la
definición de corriente verdad y la
corriente es igual a la carga dividida
entre el tiempo verdad donde la carga
por supuesto está dada en cullum y el
tiempo está dado en segundos muy bien
ahora nosotros ya sabemos la corriente
verdad de hecho es 3.00 por 10 a la 4 a
pinter es verdad entonces nosotros
tenemos que 3.000
y es a la 4 es igual a la carga dividida
entre el tiempo entonces nuestro
problema se reduce a encontrar la carga
verdad porque una vez que tengamos la
carga podemos deducir cuál es el tiempo
que le lleva a esta reacción producir
1.00 por 10 a la 3 kilogramos de sodio
así que vamos a hacer eso vamos a
encontrar la carga y nosotros podemos
empezar con la masa de sodio verdad que
de hecho ya nos dan en el enunciado esto
es 1.000 por 10 a la 3 kilogramos de
sodio entonces si pensamos cuánto es
esto en gramos claramente será 1.000 por
10 a las 6 gramos de sodio verdad
simplemente hay que multiplicar por 10 a
la 3 verdad un kilogramo son 10 a la 3
gramos ahora bien no basta con esto
nosotros tenemos que obtener cuál es el
número de moles que tenemos de sodio
verdad así que simplemente tenemos que
dividir entre la masa molar del sodio
que estoy
22.99 y entonces esto sería gramos de
sodio por mol de sodio entonces lo que
podemos ver es que los gramos de sodio
se cancelan y lo único que tenemos que
hacer es hacer esta división así que
vamos a hacer la verdad vamos a sacar
nuestra calculadora y pondremos 1.00 por
10 a las 6 y esto vamos a dividirlo
entre 22.99 bueno 22.99 y eso nos da un
resultado de 43 49 7 vamos a dejarlo
como 4.35 muy bien 4.4 punto 35 por 10 a
la 1 234 muy bien entonces esto será
igual a 4.35 por 10 a la 4 por supuesto
moles
sodio y por supuesto la pregunta es
ahora que ya tenemos los moles de sodio
entonces como es que esto nos ayuda para
encontrar la carga bueno podemos
relacionar los moles de sodio con los
moles de electrones así que vamos a
subir un poco verdad recordemos aquí de
esta reacción más bien recordemos de
esta semi reacción verdad aquí tenemos
sodio y podemos relacionarlo con los
electrones de esta semi reacción verdad
en este caso tenemos 4.35 por 10 a la 4
moles de sodio y podríamos pensar cuál
es la proporción que hay entre los moles
de electrones y los moles de sodio y
podemos ver que la proporción es 2 a 2
es decir si tenemos 4.35 por 10 a la 4
moles de sodio tendremos también 4.35
por 10 a la 4 moles pero en este caso de
electrones así que vamos a irnos de
nuevo hacia abajo en donde tenemos
ante espacio y ahora tenemos 4.35 por 10
a la 4 moles y en este caso estamos
hablando de electrones verdad y eso es
porque la proporción de moles en la semi
reacción de reducción era 2 a 2 verdad
entonces necesitamos la misma cantidad
de moles de electrones ahora lo que
podemos hacer aquí es encontrar la carga
verdad ahora que ya sabemos el número de
moles de electrones digamos podemos
utilizar la constante de faraday para
encontrar la carga total verdad y la
constante de faraday es la carga verdad
para la carga total de un molde
electrones y nosotros sabemos que eso es
96 mil 500 colones por moles por cada
molde electrones verdad entonces basta
multiplicar estos dos números para
obtener la carga total verdad por
supuesto esto se quedará en columns así
que vamos a hacerlo saquemos la
calculadora y tenemos que hacer 4
35 por 10 a la 4 que multiplica a 96 mil
muy bien y tenemos como resultado esto
que sería algo así como 4.2 por 10 a la
123456789 entonces esto será 4.2 por 10
a la 9 colom y esto es la carga total
que necesitamos verdad así que esto lo
obtuvimos a partir del número de moles
de sodio si ya tenemos la carga entonces
podemos regresar este número a esta
expresión para obtener el tiempo que le
lleva a esta reacción producir esta
cantidad de sodio que era 1.00 por 10 a
la 3 kilogramos de sodio verdad entonces
vamos a hacer eso tendremos simplemente
del lado izquierdo 3.00 por 10 a la 4 y
esto será igual a este número que hemos
obtenido 4.2 por 10 a la 9 colom
dividido entre el tiempo entonces lo que
ahora tenemos que hacer es despejar el
tiempo verdad eso simplemente se obtiene
este número entre este otro y eso eso lo
podemos hacer con la calculadora otra
vez simplemente será 4.2 por 10 a la 9
dividido entre 3.00 por 10 a la 4 muy
bien y eso nos da 1.4 por 10 a la 12 345
así que vamos a escribirlo esto será
igual el tiempo será igual a 1.4 por 10
a las 5 segundos entonces ya que tenemos
esto podríamos dejarlo así verdad es una
respuesta válida pero vamos a tratar de
tener más idea de a cuánto equivale esto
por ejemplo en minutos verdad entonces a
este resultado basta con dividirlo entre
60 para obtener el número de minutos
verdad y esos son 2 mil 333.3 minutos y
si lo volvemos a dividir entre 60
obtenemos el número de horas y eso son
38 puntos 9 horas verdad esto será
aproximadamente 38.9
y 38.9 horas este es el número de horas
que nos llevará a producir 1.00 por 10 a
la 3 kilogramos de sodio también podemos
calcular cuántos litros de gas de cloro
verdad vamos a calcular cuántos litros
de gas de cloro son producidos cuando
hacemos nuestro sodio así que digamos
que estamos a temperatura y presión
estándar verdad estamos a temperatura y
presión estándar y esto simplemente
significa que estamos a cero grados
celsius cero grados celsius para la
temperatura y nuestra presión se
encuentra a una atmósfera muy bien eso
es lo que significa que esté a
temperatura y presión estándar y hasta
ahora ya hemos visto que tratamos de
hacer 4.35 verdad 4.35 por 10 a la 4
moles de sodio verdad eso era lo que
obtuvimos anteriormente y ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es fijarnos en cuál es
la proporción de moles que hay entre el
sodio y
el cloro en forma gaseosa verdad
entonces podemos ver que la proporción
es 2 a uno verdad aquí tenemos uno
un molde clic del cloro gaseoso si
pensamos en esta proporción la
proporción de sodio y cloro tenemos que
esto es 2 a 1 verdad pero por otro lado
nosotros queríamos hacer 4.35 por 10 a
la 4 moles de sodio y ahora nos
preguntamos cuántos no les corresponden
para el cloro verdad y en este caso es
muy simple porque lo único que tenemos
que hacer es dividir entre 2 a 4.35 por
10 a la 4 moles y eso nos da el valor de
x verdad entonces simplemente tenemos
4.35 por 10 a la 4 y esto lo dividimos
entre 2 verdad y eso nos da 21 mil 750
entonces estos son 21 mil 750 moles por
supuesto
cloro gas en su forma gaseosa verdad sin
embargo nosotros queremos encontrar el
número de litros de cloro gaseoso que es
producido verdad así que una cosa que
podríamos hacer es por ejemplo para
hacernos la vida mucho más sencilla
sería decir que un molde un gas ideal
ocupa 22.4 litros a temperatura y
presión estándar así que si tenemos esta
cantidad de moles verdad lo único que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicarlo por
22.4 así que vamos a hacerlo tendremos
21.750 x 22.4 vamos a ver cuánto es esto
tendremos
21 mil 750 por 22.4 eso nos da un total
de 487 1200 vamos a dejarlo como 4.87
por 10 a la 12 345 muy bien entonces
esto es 4.87 por 10 a las 5 litros de
cloro gaseoso también hay otra forma de
hacerlo si no quieres digamos tomar el
atajo y esta forma de hacerlo es
justamente utilizando la ley
que dice que la presión por el volumen
es igual a nr t
vamos a hacer esto porque la presión y
temperatura estándar la presión es una
atmósfera cierto y la temperatura son
cero grados celsius lo que equivale a
273 punto 15 que elvin así que vamos a
hacer esto aquí tendremos una
atmósfera verdad
y vamos a tener el volumen que
esencialmente es lo que queremos
encontrar verdad ahora necesitamos poner
el número de moles y el número de moles
aquí lo tenemos son 21 mil 750 moles
verdad tendremos el valor de r que eso
es una constante de 0.08 21 y vamos a
omitir por ahora las unidades en este
caso verdad sabemos que que nos debe
quedar todo en términos de litros para
encontrar el volumen cierto entonces
aquí multiplicamos por 273 punto 15 que
elvin que son cero grados celsius muy
bien entonces esto debería darnos el
mismo resultado verdad que ya hemos
obtenido debería darnos 4.87 por 10 a
las 5 litros de cloro gaseoso muy bien
así que ya sea que lo hagamos tomando el
atajo simplemente haciendo esta
multiplicación o sustituyendo todos los
valores en esta ecuación entre de igual
a nr
y deberíamos obtener el mismo resultado
que es el volumen del cloro producido